[Music]
and um
let's play
let's play let's play d5 let's play d5
let's play a queen's game should we play
queen's game with accepted
um but this time i'm black
or shall we play something
cooler actually what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna introduce you guys to a cool line
knight c6 i'm gonna play the chigorin
um i'm gonna play the chigorin which is
one of my favorite sidelines uh against
one d4
no trust me give give the chagoran a
chance it's
it's actually really cool
give it a chance
um
i have two
favorite sub you know
sidelines within one d45 one is the
trigor and the other is the baltic which
which i taught hafu
now if white knows what to do
then the chigorin loses its luster but
at the level of a 1700 i think it's a
very good weapon
okay cd is one of the main moves
a trigon is like the equivalent of the
scandi
except within 1d4
the idea of this opening is to very
quickly pile up the pressure on the d4
pawn if you do not do that you are going
to lose in five moves so for example
here if you play bishop g4 that's too
slow black white plays knight c3 chases
the queen away then pushes the d-pawn
this is crap you have to operate
far more decisively here who knows the
move
no g6 is way too slow g6 knight c3 and
your initiative evaporates you have to
go e5
this is the only move the only way to
make it work
um
dr geek tardis thank you
yeah so if knight c3 you have bishop
before this is a very important detail
without this detail the opening wouldn't
work
um
what's the idea after dxe5 that'll talk
about after the game
e3
that's a pretty passive move and i think
that essentially gives us a nice
position
um
we can take on d4 but we don't really
have to rush with this move i think we
can also go bishop g4 get the bishop out
to an active square
um in fact that's what i'm going to do
there's no rush playing he takes d4
thank you beyond repute for the five
gifted subs much appreciated
god damn so many
so many subs today it should be two
okay now i think it's a good good time
to take because already i'm starting to
worry slightly about d takes e5
on the other hand
yeah without this knight c3 is still
not a not an idea because of bishop b4
that neutralizes it
without this idea black's position would
be as shaky as
fiddler on the roof okay let's play
takes d4 first
and then we'll castle continuing to
pressure the d4 pawn
now we castle automatic move
and look at the pressure we have on this
d4 pawn this really reminds me of a
scandi
except a really good scandi because now
the queen doesn't have to go to a5 it
can go to h5
when the time is right if
white castles
all right
oh we got a dono
oh you mean the five steps yeah
all right knight c3
now this is very interesting
now we got a donor three bucks from huge
ass crack thank you
now this is interesting because bishop
b4 already has overstayed its welcome we
don't need to play bishop before anymore
why not because d5 is no longer a threat
we already have castled we have an x-ray
going on the queen
oh that's funny i got it
that's hilarious so where should we go
with our queen
hello
that was that was not that bad though
it's like the berry one
where should we go
queen a5 queen e6 queen f5
so i just
explained the logic here we should go to
h5
queen h5 is very typical in such
positions why
because after white castles we can play
bishop d6 and start piling onto this h
pawn and go for a quick checkmating
attack if possible
clear we also
enforce more pressure on this diagonal
that's why we put the bishop on g4 d5
wow very bold
but not good he's not developing enough
pieces this pawn is going to be lost
so we're just going to go knight f6
um there's no threat of d-take c6
because of the pin so we can just attack
this fun and essentially win it
and we're going to end up a pawn up it's
not going to be crushing or anything
it's just we'll be upon up and if he
castles
ultimately we'll put a bishop on d6 and
create
big time pressure on the h2 pawn
this does resemble a scandal you know
i'm telling you i mean jaguar is like
cool scandi in many lines
yeah white is not developed enough to
sustain this pawn h3 hilarious it
doesn't create any threats either again
we have a pin on the rook
but we need to be very careful because
if white castles then there will be a
threat of taking the bishop so we
shouldn't be too nonchalant about this
right now though we don't have to
respond
we can simply do what what should black
do here
since there is no threat of hg we can
proceed with our main plan
we can take the pawn on d5 very logical
simple
doesn't require any calculation all you
have to see is that there is a pin here
the rook is undefended now we have a pin
of our own
this one's far scarier
knight takes d5 rook takes d5 and then
we put our bishop on before with check
white's position is falling apart
queen a4 good move
very good move it does threaten the
bishop
uh watch out for these kinds of lateral
moves i see a lot of blunders uh again
there's a big distance between two
pieces literally so
you just got to be very attentive to
that kind of stuff
how should we
how should we manage this well there's a
lot of ways we can play here i think
um i see something i think is kind of
cool
let me try to walk you through the
logical steps here observation one is
that white is not castled
so ideally if possible we would like to
exploit the fact that white is not
castled and
do something can we do something
well
how do you usually attack a king that's
not castle usually you attack a king
that's not castle through the e-file
right now there is a bishop
that's on e2 which is blocking the e
file
so from that perspective taking the
knight would be very sensible in order
to essentially get the bishop off of the
e file bishop takes f3 bishop takes f3
and in that next position how should we
continue
not rookie 8 because then our queen is
going to be hanging our knight is going
to be hanging
how should we proceed after bishop takes
bishop takes
bishop b4 is a great move here by the
way as well i think that's an alternate
approach queen swings over to e5
checks the king and hits the knight on
c3
if white takes with the pawn then the
entire king side is ruined that's also
very beneficial
so in either case i think we're going to
win more material
hopefully that makes sense i'm trying to
be very methodical in the explanation
this is a great example of a move which
strategically doesn't make much sense
because our light squared bishop is very
good but tactically makes
is justified because we are exploiting
a
temporary feature of the position
which
would evaporate on the next move
okay so that's
at this level chess is like constantly
an interplay between
between those two things okay now we
obviously
take on c3 twice and white is in huge
trouble because he's down two pawns and
there's forks galore
lots of stuff going on boom boom
this rook is hanging if he goes rook b1
there's a fork on d3 on deck
white is losing he can give us a check
on g4 doesn't do anything we just tuck
our king on b8
don't be afraid of these individual
checks thank you spot over the raid 115
damn girl
[Music]
we got
we're getting tons of raids tons of subs
lots of hype love to see it thank you
guys thank you badour you had a good
tournament
[Music]
we are doing some speed running with
subs
rook b1
goodbye queen d3 wins the rook
yeah chagoran is a dubious opening if
white plays correctly but it hasn't been
refuted it's not like it good game
it's not like it's it's it's trash
all right
yes
okay great great game
all right all right all right all right
that's right
okay let's have a look
so
the chigorin
the chigorin was not first played by
trigoran
it was first played by
a guy named van der lassa
who was an early opening specialist back
at home in san francisco i have
one of his manuscripts from the
early 19th century he was a german
player he played this in 1837.
in fact the trigorian was played twice
three times in 1837 trigoran only played
it in 1894
but it's very important to understand
i i've said this many times and an
opening is named after someone it
doesn't necessarily mean they played it
first very often they were only like the
fifteenth or twentieth person to play
but jagoran played this opening
over 15 times
and if you guys want i could probably
find what chagoran had to say about it
it's a pretty
hard move to play if you don't know if
you don't know it exists because it's
extremely committal you're blocking the
c pawn you're going directly for white's
center
the chagoran is good chagoran yeah
i'm not going to talk too much opening
theory you guys can do your own research
i think
in modern times the best move is
considered to be knight c3
the best move is considered to be knight
c3 this takes the sting out of the
chagoran and if d takes c4 then you go
either d5 or just knight f3 followed by
d5
and here black is in quite a bit of
trouble so i think this is
the reason it's lost some of its luster
but i can try some moves like e5 still
very interesting
um you can google it so let's say you
wanted to do some research on an opening
the best thing to do is just to google
it or to search it on youtube and you're
probably going to find some tutorial on
it
but you should use the internet
and you can also use this on chess.com
there is a opening explorer feature
which is really good so you can use that
as well
uh but don't just sit there sort of
twiddling your thumbs and
you know the internet is very very
very very um
how should i put it underrated resource
for learning openings
all right so knight f c takes d5 is is
the traditional main move and knight f3
is already not that good uh the move
here is e3
e3 e5
knight c3 bishop b4 this is the
traditional main line bishop d2
bishop takes c3 b takes e3 this is one
of the key positions of the chagoran
very interesting pawn structure white
gets this triangle white gets the two
bishops but black gets very quick
development and white's king is often in
trouble in these lines
i think according to theory white is
better here but you got to know your
stuff
um
that's
the path that white should go on if you
take on d5 but knight f3 e5 is already
good for black i think or already not
bad
if d takes e5
should black take the queen
let's see spam whether you think black
should take the plane
okay most of you think yes
which is pretty impressive uh i like it
black should take the queen
of course black should take the queen
what would be the argument against
taking the queen the argument against it
would be isn't black down a pawn when
you're down upon you don't want to trade
pieces i'm sure some of you are thinking
that it's not an embarrassing thing to
think
but
first of all all of the other pieces are
still on the board which essentially
makes this a queenless middle game
the other thing to realize is that this
pawn on e5 while it's an extra pawn is
not going to be sustained forever you're
going to go bishop g4
already black threatens to win the pawn
back
and if bishop f4 there is a typical
maneuver
knight g to e7 swings over to g6 white
cannot hold the spawn and even if black
white could hold the spawn
black has massive compensation white's
king is very weak it's right in the path
of a long castle with check black gets
very quick development so
you have to think more concretely than
that
so that's why taking it on e5 is not
good
i think white could still maintain a
decent position
by playing
um so bishop e2 is fine
here
i think
there is a final opportunity to get an
interesting position
but you have to know this move this is
not an easy move to just come up with
and that move is knight c3 it's actually
not an not an atypical idea when you
have a queen on d5 i can show you many
lines that have a move like this
uh and if bishop b4 white can simply
castle
the ship bishop takes e3 bc and white's
trying to take the spawn on his own
terms what should black do here
instructive question for you guys what
should black do in this position
in fact it's an only move otherwise why
does black is much worse
oh my god we got 100 bucks we actually
got 100 bucks shalish money
your lessons are very helpful thank you
oh my god
ridiculous
we've got a hundred from shailesh mani
thank you so much resign yeah that is
correct
okay
this is not correct
what would happen if we castle let's
figure it out
white would play c takes d4
look very carefully at whites a black's
king and look at white's king white's
king is perfectly safe black's king is
devastated
because you have two semi-open files
white's going to occupy one of them with
his rook this is going to be very bad
for black and it's going to decline very
quickly bishop is going to come to a3
rook is going to come to c1 queen to a4
black is black's kang is going to be
devastated here
all right so what you want to do is give
away the pawn on your own terms you want
to go pawn to d3 a lot of you got this
you're essentially keeping a bad pawn
structure
and if white takes to the bishop
and you can play bishop takes f3 to
start with
forcing more ruining of the pawn
structure and this is already lost for
white
why is it lost because the bishop is
hanging and if it moves you swing over
to g5 with the queen
so white probably has to take on d3 with
a queen and the end game
an end game like this is probably fine
for black white as the two bishops but
look at white's pawn structure it's
absolutely horrible i think black is in
fine shape here probably not better but
fine
so one
shortcut toward evaluating king safety
when you have opposite side castling is
to see who's got the open files
which side has an easier time getting
rooks to open files and getting the
queen to a good attacking spot
here it's clearly white white's got two
of these semi-open files and white's got
this a4 square for the queen
so
you can remember that as a easy way to
kind of estimate who's got an easier job
of attacking
okay whoa jim james here and he's here
with 25 subs
what a stream thank you gem jam for the
25
let's get this hype rolling
great stuff
[Music]
oh my lance
all right
all right so
before i get rudely interrupted
he takes the 4864 castle here already i
think
there's a high probability that white is
white is in a little bit of trouble the
computer actually shows still an
advantage for white after castles which
is very surprising to me
but it turns out that after bishop d6h3
white holds on
and everything hinges on one detail if
bishop takes h3
what should white do here
thank you fizz girl for the prime
white should certainly not take the
bishop because then queen h3 was a huge
attack but there's a very typical idea
in such positions
exploiting the x-ray to go knight g5
and you're attacking the queen
bishop g4 you guys might be tempted by
this but bishop takes you for is to
check
and if the queen moves then knight takes
h3 white preserves the kingside pawn
structure and is up a piece
so in this position black should
actually go knight f6 and
sacrifice the bishop this way
but after knight g4 g3
queen h3 yeah it's anybody's game this
is very unclear and now the computer
starts saying that black is better so
i think that practically speaking the
position's very difficult here d5 though
is a mistake
after d5 white is losing knight f6 and
now this pawn falls
now knight d5 takes yeah bishop f3
bishop f3 queen e5 is the winning idea
here how do you donate um i think exclam
donate
we'll give you the link
thank you bass bishop if 92 then we give
sorry we give a check on b4 with a
crushing attack
king f1 knight d4 is a great move
indicated by the engine
if knight d4 queen e1 is made
crushing
any questions so
to summarize the key mistake here for
white
i think going into this line is already
not not great knight c3 here is the way
to go if you want to take the sting out
um
here this is fine
knight c3 is actually a very important
way move to castle as quickly as
possible after edie castles you get a
pretty bad scandy type position maybe
bishop e3 here preserves a reasonable
position but
this is what we want on the trigger and
black gets a desirable position
all right
um
any questions
that are not as general as how to find
the best plan
all right i'm down for one more game
um
maybe we're the radcliff
all right let's play the second
interesting sideline
that i advocate we're not going to play
the chagoran again we are going to play
the baltic bishop f5
and
those of you have been on my stream for
a long time i have played this
with other gm's i i this is a reputable
move
and it contains a ton of traps it's very
interesting
and it's
it's similar in a way to the trigorin
where
if c takes d5 the idea is to quickly
root this knight out so it can't come to
c3
in this position you go e6 and the
secondary idea is that you essentially
get like a queen's gambit with the
bishop outside the pawn chain
so
that's the positional justification of
the baltic now there is a downside to it
which is that when you develop your
bishop this early
there's a couple of bad things about
this line one of them is the queen b3 is
always going to be dangerous this hits
two pawns at the same time
if you're a baltic specialist though you
know that this is not actually a scary
move in this position does anybody know
how black should react here
what you should not do is try to defend
both pawns at the same time you can't do
that you have to create a counter threat
asap
what what might that look like well
you can notice the bishop the bishop
controls c2 so there's ideas of putting
a knight on b4
the second thing is that the pawn on d4
is undefended you can hit both by
playing knight c6
this leads to very interesting
complications if white is not careful he
can lose very quickly here
if e3 then we go knight b4 looks very
childish but it's actually hard to stop
knight c2
all right i already think white needs to
start worrying about equality here i'm
not sure how i should play
queen takes b7 knight takes d4
is extremely nasty knight c2 is
threatened
yeah now i'm just trying to expose
people to new new ways of playing
because i see so many people just
basically play whatever they
you know play whatever they know and
if you're stuck with an opening that
doesn't fit your style it can really
delay your development
um queen b3
is a good move
in this position but i think c takes d5
is a mistake okay vadi thank you for the
prime so
knight before obviously
and i'm pretty sure knight f3 is correct
but white has to be extremely precise
here
the threat is knight c2 with a fork the
secondary threat is bishop c2 and the
queen is almost trapped it has to step
into the line of this other bishop
so knight c2 is not the only threat in
this position
let's see if he's able to find the i
think the only move
yeah e4 you guys are
very sharp e4 is i believe
essentially the only move
essentially the only move
all right
there's just no other way to stop these
two moves thank you yeah thank you betty
for the prime
this is essentially the fried lover idea
of putting a bishop here a knight here
it exists in many openings
yeah i think he's struggling with this
move e4 is not easy to play
because it it gives up a pawn but at
least it clogs up the bishop
and then white can go knight e5
and create a mate threat on f7
thank you dk d k t q 80 and piece 42 for
the primes
good stuff going on
yeah if he plays it we'll we'll cross
that bridge when we get there
how would you respond to e4 well we're
going to take that pawn we have no other
choice after 95 i think we'll drop the
bishop back to e6
trying to defend against the mate with
tempo
thank you ishkey for the prime
wow
three months e4 he finds it good good
stuff
let's play de4
and 95.
all right
so
we must defend against the may threat
how are we going to do that well
um
there's a couple of approaches here no
e3 would blundermate
knight h6 would be awesome but
unfortunately that knight can be
captured we don't want that
queen e7
is interesting but very awkward we
blocked the bishop
white can go a3 we have to play with
tempo here there's no doubt about it so
the only thing i see is bishop e6
process of elimination whether or not
this move is good doesn't matter we got
to do it
yeah
sub with prime free
i never i never uh guilt people into
something
queen f6 is the same problem it doesn't
occur with tempo white plays a3
and we can't really move the knight
because we're going to lose b7 in a very
bad version thank you there we go erod y
of the prime
[Music]
thank you
mob zombie with a prime
there we go
bishop c4 excellent move
all right
let's untangle this position
the immediate temptation is to take on
c4 queen takes c4
knight
c to check
thank you jay lev and adrian with the
subs
but in that position if the king moves
aside we still will have to deal with
the maid threat
um
so
knight c2 is not as amazing of an idea
as it seems
i'm gonna think for a second
yeah so
it appears to be one of those situations
where
we should give up our extra pawn
and remove the immediate threats that's
what i think we should do yeah we can go
knight c2 first but then he just takes
it the knight on e5 defends the bishop
on c4 you guys are all pointing to the
right idea i think
which is either to do this immediately
or to start by taking on c4
let's do this i think this is a little
bit more forcing
um
and after queen takes c4 go knight d3
check and basically say all right i'm
going to force the nitrate and get rid
of this incredibly pesky night but i'm
gonna let you take that extra pawn so
the position might be about equal at the
end
i don't know we'll think about it
are there alternatives to that move
there probably are
we can even play queen e7 here that's
not as bad of a move as it used to be
oh actually queen e7 is very interesting
no queen takes d4 still queen f7 and
then queen takes f8 checkmate
knight d3 check knight takes d3
e takes d3 queen takes c3 looks about
equal also we're very underdeveloped
there
um
i like the idea of going queen e7 here
what's the difference because now
white's queen is no longer on b3 and
after queen a7 a3 can be met with knight
c2 fork
um i like this move more than i like
queen f6 because queen f6 walks into
knight takes e4 with tempo
after queen e7 knight takes c4 is not
with tempo we can probably play f6 there
another detail if queen b5 check here
looks very nasty
but we play c6 and the queen actually
defends b7
so i think queenie seven is the best
move and finally this paves the way for
an eventual long castle which is very
often the case of the baltic
yeah sure i'll i'll explain why knight
t3 was not the move after the game
i actually prefer black's position i
don't see what he's going to do against
the threat of f6
this is a very dangerous line yeah you
if you play the baltic you should be
prepared to lose some games quickly
but you also should be prepared to win
some games quickly
that's why if you play an opening like
this you have to know the theory
you just you can't waltz into a line
like this and just expect that
everything's going to
pan out nicely
how it works
okay
we'll see
uh what's the best move here maybe the
castle maybe a3 i don't know
we need to that doesn't look
that looks like an admission of
essentially not of defeat but
that this allows us to breathe breathe
easy so what should we do here we can
play the immediate knight d3
knight takes d3 e takes d3 and that pawn
is untouchable due to the pin so we
force a queen trade
but i don't see the need to do that i
think we can play
ah but no f6 there's queen h5 check
maybe we should do that
ah no there's actually a very
interesting line there
okay i've calculated a very interesting
line
oh my god
actually crazy
what a mess
i confess
yeah let's go for the mess
or or shall we just go knight t3 and
take a small advantage in the end game
well you love a mess but i don't know if
i love passes
i'm trying to make sense of this insane
position
okay this is probably on sound but we're
going to go for f6
this is probably on sound but we're
going to go for the mess
it seems the theme today is
tactical craziness
currently we are up a pawn
right as of this moment
we are up upon thank you witches pink
geez wow
impressive
g6 thank you ready steady weep
priming
all right so
this is a ridiculous position
um
and the idea here is actually to use the
idea of knight c2
so we take on g6 this is a simple idea
queen takes h8 and then we win the rook
and white takes the knight leading to an
insane position probably white is better
right king f1 is correct very impressive
queen takes g8 and then we long castle
we have to get our king out of the
center immediately
and material is now equal because he is
taken upon on g6
yeah maybe queen f7 was better i don't
know
i feel like this is more straightforward
wow whoa
what was that queen h3 is very weird
he's trying to stop us from castling but
i think he got confused now we're just
up a piece and we can play f5
intercepting the queen you forgot to
take the knight
after such a good game
wow
that is sag
guys stop with the sniping
allegations
let's put some more trust into people
yeah queen h3 is weird
always ask yourself what if you were
playing well would you like people to
just accuse you immediately of sniping
um
i don't think that's
how you would like people to react if
you're trying really hard and playing
well
not to say it's not possible but there's
there's nothing we can do about it if
somebody wants to listen then then
they're listening fine whatever but
it's you know
we don't want to resort to that
accusation when somebody just finds some
good moves
the priorities to get the night out but
the knight is not in immediate trouble
because c2 cannot be covered by white's
queen
we don't need to rush with knight c2 we
can start by castling we can even get
our king side pieces out and we can play
only knight c2 when we need to
there is no rush
bishop f4 yeah we can castle
and only if he plays king e2 for example
do we get the knight out of a1
no immediate rush yeah
okay
so again in such positions when you've
won a piece you want to prioritize what
are the priorities priority number one
is to get the king out of the center
that's obvious priority number two i
would say is develop the rest of our p
okay knight p5
so i think here we can go after him
how should we play well um it's clear
that the king and f1 is essentially a
sitting duck
we have a very nice move here i think
and rather than getting a piece out or
going c6 c6 would be bad because of
knight takes a7
a6 is perfectly fine but we can attack
this knight with our queen we can kill
two birds with one stone
i think we can go queen b4
good job frost
get the queen into the game attack the
knight we don't care about knight take
c7 it's just not dangerous
then we can play rook takes d4 and go
for checkmate
it appears we won't even need
our other
pieces i think we should actually start
with the track to corner the king even
further
and then play rook takes d4 and crash
through along the first rank
easy stuff here
yeah the knight and the bishop are
currently
on vacation
if he goes to the other side we can go
bishop before check
get the bishop out
okay this is mate
should be too forced and after bishop d2
start thinking about the fastest way to
check me
yeah this was an easy game too to mess
up
okay once we have many ways to mate
but what's the most elegant
most elegant is to use this pin
and go very nice queen c1
easy easy move
take the bishop
and checkmate on e1
great game
just one bad move i think radcliffe got
confused but nicely done nonetheless
um
[Music]
good stuff
all right good game great game great
game um sorry that yeah
so
the baltic bishop f5 i don't know why
it's called the baltic maybe it was
played in latvia for the first time
it was played for the first time by
edward lasker distant cousin of emmanuel
and i have something hilarious to say to
you guys
um
would you like to know
the position that arose in
lasker's game after was knight c3 e6
and actually lasker's opponent played
queen b3
and this guy actually edward lasker
did see knight c6 very impressive e3
knight before this happened in last
year's game and he won
um cd ed e4 very similar game uh to the
first time that this was ever played
thank you varn tala var
tanla for the prime
i would say it's a great weapon for
intermediate players but probably not as
an exclusive line
um
but it's a good thing to have
in your pocket if you play if you're
playing somebody who is not super
theoretical obviously c takes d5 the
question is what do we do because
after queen takes d5 it would be
ridiculous to play like why are we doing
this knight c3 e4 is bad
so that's the idea of bishop f5 is
revealed here bishop takes b1 get the
knight out
rook there's also queen a4 in this
position
but basically after queen d5
this is a similar thing to the chagoran
if white plays materialistically and you
go knight c6 very quickly you go e5 and
assault right center
knight f3 you castle and i've won some
very quick games here even for ruja
uh i want a quick game against version
he played bishop d3 here and wanted a
piece but it's a function of this line
that people kind of lose their minds
here black is already in very good shape
because this pawn cannot be held
so one way successful way to play the
baltic is to actually sacrifice this
pawn and go knight f3 not easy to do
queen takes a2 there's queen c2 white
gets a very big development advantage
this is
one of the ways to challenge the baltic
um
the other way to challenge the baltic is
knight c3
but now rather than going queen b3 just
to go knight f3 this is a good way to
get a slight advantage
knight c6
now do not go e3 very common mistake due
to knight b4
and here if white plays z4 tries to give
up a pawn you have this queen takes d4
idea which i showed hafu and black is
going to be up two pawns
typical
okay so here you either want to go eight
sorry
you either want to go a3 stop knight
before or even better you want to go
bishop g5 get the bishop out
bishop b7 bishop takes c7 often black
takes with this knight to be able to
move the c pawn
white is slightly better here white's
got a pretty pleasant position
and so
you know
um there are ways to get an advantage
against the baltic
but um
but it's nonetheless it's a very good
one even this position is
only very slightly better for white
you're going to go c6 knight f6
castle
and i've i've won games with black this
in this way
all right
um c d e d queen b3
knight c6 thank you not that paul for
the prime
and already white has to be very careful
thank you amen three three nine one for
the prime
thank you so much i appreciate it
lots of hype knight f3 knight b4
and
it turns out that after e4 probably
white is still
in very good shape he takes c4 knight e5
yeah so i'm checking this with the
engine and actually queen e7 is a
mistake
you guys were correct
um after castles black's position is
very dangerous
f6
and very computerish move a3 apparently
white is almost winning here
because if you move this knight
who sees the crushing move for white
not oh yeah there is also a check but
knight d5 is just complete destruction
queen knight pawn everything
um for this reason you have to take but
after eight takes before a look at
black's king again you cannot castle
because now the a file is open black is
in big trouble
why not queen takes d4 this is a classic
tunnel vision move
do not focus only on the cool part of
your idea
look at it from your opponent's
perspective is white gonna take on d4
oh you haven't actually stopped it takes
f7
this is checkmate
very common source of blunder very often
blunders are moves that actually contain
a cool idea
what happens is you get fixated on that
idea and you don't approach it
objectively and consider alternatives
for your opponent
so just be very careful when you're
making a flashy move make sure you're
honest with yourself about whether you
actually calculated
possibilities so 93 was the best move
this equalized
takes takes i was concerned about this
position
that because of the lack of king side
development white is going to get a
quick e-file attack
but it turns out that after bishop d6
black is okay if rookie one check you
can go 97 and quickly castle and white's
advantage
is very slight at most
um
what about queen before before the
bishop trade ah
here there's bishop take c6 i'm not sure
what you guys had in mind but this is
very bad
because f7 is falling takes bishop f7
you have to move your king
and if you play fee then obviously queen
e6 crushing attack
oh yeah queen takes d5 here then there
is knight takes d4 you don't need to
trade queens
bishop is
white is collapsing here because knight
c2 there's no defense
if queen b7 also knight f4 and again
this is very bad knight c2 is coming the
queen is completely innocuous
so
in this position
castles was best and after queen e2
i played f6 i think i should have
probably just castled first
but i really wanted to go down this
interesting line f6 queen h5 here here
okay so
at first i thought that black is winning
with the move queen f7 at first i
thought this was winning why
this is a classic way to defend against
this mechanism because
you can't take the rook
and if the knight moves back to f4 do
not forget about knight c2 we trade
queens so we win the rook
but
when your king is in the center you
should always look for these
intermediate checks so white can swing
the queen over
c6
and again queen is hanging knight is
saying black is winning right
no if you look more carefully
you will find knight takes h8 attacking
the queen cool details here takes takes
black has to go knight c2 maybe black is
fine here but
um
actually this knight might be trapped so
it's an unclear position this was one
way to play
but i didn't calculate after knight
takes h8 so that's why i took
boom boom boom boom boom
yeah and here queen takes g8
results in a very messy position
one possibility is to trade queens go
queen f7 i think it's an equal end game
yeah it happens but i was going to play
castles
queen takes g6 and rook takes d4 with
crazy complications probably white is
better if white just pushes the pawn
and the problem is that d1 square is
very nicely protected by the knight so
i don't know
i think this happens sometimes when
you're in messy positions that's why you
want more experience in these types of
positions the more experience you have
the less
you hallucinate the less you have these
kinds of
sudden blunders
so it's very good i think to expose
yourself to crazy positions you get
better at
sorting through the chaos
yeah amazingly played i mean if if not
for this move you you hung with me
completely and in fact after castles
you're almost winning so
of course
practically this is not so simple but
uh but objectively black is in big
trouble here
thank you
very well played
[Music]